the sandals resort in Russia looks way
worse than it did in the brochure
nothing better than being barefoot on a
gravel beach with your Bros eating live
poisonous fish it's like a jello shot
for Mother Nature
it's time to get into swimsuit shape and
there's no better way to do that then by
eating one pound of rich creamy unsalted
butter there you go folks
one pound of gray double leg butter
and the perch have found
harvest one of the best things about
having a staff is making them do
whatever the hell I want my favorite
employee to mess with is my tour manager
Andrew I've been forcing him to eat
unpleasant stuff on camera all season
long this is warm bacon flavored soda
[Laughter]
what is it if they big nut press - no no
babies ready okay - things that couldn't
be combined
what is he going to chickenhead
[Music]
[Applause]
yes and cutting fruit is dangerous
that's why in my office we have a strict
new no peeling policy
[Music]
we also had a coconut even though I
firmly believe it's a nut not a fruit
what I like to do after I finished a
full rotation put it in reverse catch
the stragglers Anne Hathaway can do that
in half the time she's like four rows of
teeth I think the faster eat your
veggies the sooner you can have dessert
you